we'll kind of start doing the little
intro bit my name's ian cooper
uh and what i'm gonna try and endeavor
to talk to you about today is that one
of the problems i tend to see quite a
bit out there for folks
uh doing so messaging wanted event
driven architectures is
they struggle with this idea of
when do i send and receive a message
because at that point i become
asynchronous
and hey i really want some kind of
synchronous response here surely to my
request and can i really wait and
latency
right and
you know even
even where i work currently uh i see a
lot of teams going oh yeah but the
latency of making a call and
um and a lot of it is about how we think
about work right
and uh and how we've modeled
what the divisions of that
responsibility will be
and what i'm going to do today is look
at some older ideas
that will give us a
different and perhaps better perspective
on how we should divide the work up to
support being asynchronous
it should be a nice
gentle straightforward post lunch
session
uh any one of you feels like it can
snooze in the back that's fine
um but there shouldn't be anything too
hard here
oh my this just says that i'm old it
also says that i
encourage you not to believe that people
standing here are somehow elevated above
you we are all just
people i have been doing this a while i
have some things to share you all have
things to share whether you know it or
not with people around you the people
that don't know what you know and i'd
encourage you all to think about
having a go at speaking it's very scary
at first but it does get better
there any net devs in the room i work on
an open source project called brighter
we do
for net platforms um please check us out
if you're interested
uh i'm going to talk about three things
so first for anyone who was in my
session
yesterday apologies we're going to do a
brief
slew slides that were there yesterday
we're just going to say what what i mean
by synchronous asynchronous conversation
and then we're going to go and look back
in the past of the world of paper
workflows i am old enough to have worked
in what we call a pre-automation office
with paper workflows and i'll explain to
you how they can effectively help us
reason about asynchronous
uh flying systems because it turns out
paper-based pre-automation offices were
mostly asynchronous
working at an idea from the
1970s and early 80s called flow-based
programming which was
um there was flow-based programming
there was object orientation one of them
one the other one perhaps deserves a
little bit of us looking again at some
of its ideas
and then i'll talk a little bit
practically about how you can try using
these insights with approaches like
value stream mapping and event storming
to understand how to slice up your your
system so that it can support
asynchronous work
okay
so what do i mean by a synchronous
conversation
uh so in a synchronous conversation both
parties must be present for
communication to succeed so the classic
example would be something like a phone
call right
i pick up the phone i call you in order
for that to be a successful
communication
you have to be at the other end and pick
up the phone
if you are not there
my conversation with you won't succeed
in an asynchronous conversation
the receiver doesn't need to be present
at the time
and the senator communicates with them
using a store and forward to pick up the
message later so a mailbox
right i send you something it goes in
your mailbox you can be out shopping you
come back you pick it up
and you and you read my uh my message to
you
that's has huge advantages
because it means we are not temporarily
coupled we don't have to both be
available at the same time
in order for communication to succeed
now i don't know about you but uh
nowadays nearly all the communication i
do with people
um tends to be
uh via some sort of messaging right
whatsapp slack you know uh not by
basically phone call any person that
phones with my mum and she is in her 80s
so she gets an excuse basically for
phoning me and i can remember you know
back in the 80s
early 90s before really things like text
were common trying to organize a night
out on friday with your friends was a
nightmare because it's phoning everybody
up and they're not there they're on a
desk and a meeting now you just hop on
what's up what's happening a message
right
so exactly the same reasons that we all
find
asynchronous conversations to be much
easier
they actually are much easier for our
software systems too
because they remove this problem of
temporal coupling
so
where can we learn about how we succeed
with asynchronous
workflows
so one place to really look is back in
the past when before we had automated
offices things were done with paper
so i currently work for justice takeaway
imagine that i decided i was going to
create a business
in a pre-automation world that wanted a
similar business model which is i am
going to deliver you food from a
restaurant restaurants will sign up with
my business
right i will then ship a catalogue to
your house you'll come to the letterbox
the junk mail for you
you and when you want to order some food
you'll look in my paper catalogue and
you'll go hmm i fancy that you'll phone
me up one of my order tags will take the
order we will fax
the order to the restaurant the
restaurant will cook it and then someone
will deliver it right we can do it all
with telephones fax machines and pieces
of paper right
and i think hopefully what you'll see is
a bit of insight
into how we used to do asynchronous
processes
now this is a i'll show you how to build
these later on this is about a value
stream map
what it's showing you is a particular
flow this is basically probably what we
call an environmental flow it supports
our business and this is onboarding a
new restaurant top is there so a
restaurant saying i want to be part of
just paper takeaways business want to be
in the catalog
and so what would happen initially the
first process we look at is essentially
somebody's going to phone our sales team
and our sales team essentially are going
to say okay here's how you sign up
here's how much it costs is what we take
from the order come to a deal with the
restaurant these things refer to lead
time how long it takes before the queue
is
processing time how long effective it
takes to actually deal with one of these
items how many of them succeed
goes to our team that manage menus right
they're going to take the menu details
from you
and they're going to put the menu
details into basically our catalog and
we're going to publish that and it will
go out basically to all the customers
right
so how do we do that okay
a couple of things you need to know
on the left this is the typical
pre-automation desk
we have the outbox and the inbox and
they are what they say on the tin right
the inbox is where things you need to
action or information to support you
actually things arrive and the outbox is
where you put things that you have done
the idea is work comes into my inbox i
am busy i process stuff at my desk and
when i'm done it i pass it to the outbox
and a key concept here
is
the bit of the time when i'm effectively
trying to be synchronous is essentially
when i'm actively working on an item
right i might make a phone call
something like that that affects me in
order to clarify something then when it
goes to the outbox i am that
asynchronous the inbox
right outbox that inbox is asynchronous
so what happens is someone comes by with
a mail cart
let's call him franz kafka so kafka
delivers messages
between
inboxes and outboxes right
what gets sent we'll use a couple of
these things
so on the left hand side
we can think of these as our events
right so generally you send one of these
envelopes and you put on the name
routing information would go on the
front you say who's it for and inside
usually a memo or a small or a short
letter which basically says please can
you do this it's a request for some kind
of immediate action or a notification
saying just be aware that x has happened
all right so you can think about these
as skinny messages and they're screened
off immediately action
the other thing that flows around the
building are files
and files represent the information that
you may need to carry out one of these
actions customer details history
um
all sorts of information and big fat
things so we can think about those as
doc what we call document or fact
messages
they're often not immediately action
they often support action right and
they're often basically what we call
series rather than discrete you get a
whole set of them
final thing you might want to know it's
less important to our example but just
because i had to work my first sort of
job before university um i i got i
worked in them at one of these mail
rooms doing this this is what they call
the frame
and what happens is they think there's
our broker franz kafka comes with his
car and we basically take all the stuff
out we sort it into basically
pigeon holes for floors and then
basically someone takes delivering to
that floor and takes the message across
this is a primitive broker right it's
routing
things to their destination
oh yeah one more thing those who haven't
seen it i assume everyone you guys have
all seen fax machines right they still
exist enough for the youngsters in the
audience
that's i can send paper between two
places right
excellent
so this is typically how it might work
i'm a restaurant owner
and i want to join this amazing new
business just paper takeaway i think
this is really really going to increase
the orders to my restaurants so i get my
phone and i make a synchronized
conversation
and it goes to the sales team at just
paper takeaway
and they take down my details and they
say fantastic we're signing you up
i'll get one of our menu people to phone
you and take details of your menu and
what i do is the sales person as i
probably open a file
saying hey i've got this ongoing sales
process
and i put basically a request one of the
discreet fraction items in my out box
saying hey menu team please can you
contact this customer and get their menu
details
kafka comes along and he collects stuff
and puts it in his mail cart and he
delivers it over to
the team that deal with menus
team would do with menus take it out
their inbox and they probably open a
file too saying okay i've got a menu
request i need to deal with because it's
going to take some time and i'm going to
need to basically correlate the
responses when they come in
i then fax the restaurant right i faxed
the restaurant saying please can you
fill out basically your menu for our
catalogue
over at the restaurant someone takes the
facts and they may well open a file too
saying oh another one of these menu
requests from these newfangled um
paper-based main
delivery companies um i will effectively
put a request in the chefs in the inbox
for the chef and the chef can create a
menu basically for this company
so it goes over to the chef's desk it
goes to his inbox from your outbox by
um uh probably uh franz kafka's cousin
uh who works in the restaurant and and
kafka effectively takes it to the chef
and the chef then basically fills out
the menu and puts it in his out box
from the outbox franz takes it basically
to the team that confirmed the request
they essentially say right we're done
take it off in their file and say that
particular action is done and they fax
it back to us
we then pick it up over basically in the
process menu request team and they say
okay where's the file for that one okay
so when we've done that piece of work
okay that's complete and i can put
something in the out box with the
details probably the whole file in for
the team that actually builds menus
clean the builds menus effectively gets
it in their inbox and they go away and
they do some reprographics work and they
update the basic new catalog which is
dispatched to all our happy lovely
customers right
and you can see
the only real synchronous part of that
flow
is when the call is made
to us basically to request that we put
you in the menu everything else
is a flow from inboxes to outboxes with
some busy work in the middle
such as effectively completing menu
details
right
but what we're doing is we're moving
between these process steps
and these flows are naturally
asynchronous we can have pauses to wait
for stuff to come back
um someone heard the messaging term
routing slip
something you might have yeah so this is
actually a routine this is what they
actually look like
um so you can see it's basically like a
workflow and has a list of people
oh it means that person retains it at
the end and it's saying either this
information for you in other words i
want you to know that this is happening
or action you have an action to take and
basically what happens is you just go
through each person in the list and they
do what they're supposed to do we use
that messaging all the time the idea
effectively that a message could contain
the workflow
that it should be following
okay
so i sent out my menu
someone basically now wants to place an
order with our fabulous business okay
so the customer wants to order food
so there's an order food process where
they phone up one of our lovely agents
they could i could make even this
asynchronous and assume businesses will
fax it in right but for the minute we're
assuming domestic customers don't have a
fax machine and they're going to phone
us up
um they'll take the order they'll pass
over to the payments team in fact we
only have a certain number of people who
can take credit cards
right they'll take the order um once the
order is paid for um it will go to our
order placement team who will then put
it out to a given restaurant and once
the restaurant confirms that they're
going to put they're going to fulfill
the order our customer agents will phone
back the customers or text them and say
your order's on its way
so how does that work well
the customer has a catalog
we sent them one asynchronously they
have received instructions which let
them place an order with us anyone who
isn't familiar with it should probably
read a white paper by pat helen called
the data on the outside versus data on
the inside and pat talks about an idea
he calls reference data so reference
data is data that we need to publish to
other services in order to help them
make requests
and commonly when we do it by messaging
the term we tend to use nowadays is
event carriage state transfer which
means i use messaging to let you build
up uh the data you will need to send me
your request
right
so that just equip we do exactly the
equivalent of this i give you a catalog
so you can make an order and the same
thing is true you know for uis right my
cert my micro service publishes data
that you can then use in the ui actually
to make requests okay
and they place the order and they phone
up my team to place the order
my team also has the catalog why well
when the customer phones up
i need to validate the order right i
need to basically go through validate
that's a correct order for that
restaurant figure out what the price is
say to the customer hey that's going to
be you know 24 pounds etc
note that we may have issues with
eventual consistency what do we mean by
that well typically what happens is some
of our customers they put this in their
draw they get a new one and they're kind
of like we've already got one of those
and throw it away and so they're
ordering from an out-of-date set of data
right
so what happens we have to resolve those
eventual consistency issues which tends
to mean
that our team has actually the correct
copy of the lookup data that they need
and they will simply tell the customer
i'm afraid you can't order that item or
no actually that's now gonna be 27
pounds rather than 24 because the prices
have gone up is that okay we resolve
those issues all the time
in normal workflows in the kind of
business
now they probably use the phone system
to put you on hold transfer you to
somebody who can take a payment they
will basically use our card machine
which has a basically an option for
cardholder not present we'll put through
the card machine effectively and if we
take the payment successfully from you
then the take payment team can basically
put an order in their outbox saying
there's a priced and validated order
from a customer
and again
there's a synchronous flow
which occurs basically from the customer
to the order taker
you can think about someone filling out
basically information on a website
but at that point effectively the
synchronous flow continues although we
kind of do a
a little bit of a kind of sync over
async over sync right we let we don't
have to we allow the auto taker take new
orders while effectively um we transfer
to the other payment person and then
essentially at that point we
uh raise an order
so
go into restaurants this is basically
actually still how restaurants tend to
do this today this is called the order
wheel
so they can take it as a message queue
what happens i got a piece of paper on
the waitress with somebody's order i go
and stick it basically on the next
available
slot on the order wheel the chef comes
along rotates it round clockwise takes
the next item in turn and basically
fulfills that order right
so people all the time use things like
messaging message cues asynchronous
flows right in the real world all the
time that's what we do
okay
so i have project processed and
validated order and that arrives in my
order placement team it goes into their
inbox it's basically just a order
request so it will be a simple uh inside
a simple envelope there's no file
required and essentially they say okay i
need to look up basically some details
i've got about the restaurant we don't
really show that here but somewhere
they've probably got a book that gives
the restaurants fax numbers they get the
fax number for the restaurant and they
fax the order over to the restaurant
the order taking team the restaurant
basically effectively uh will
essentially take it off the fax machine
they probably essentially put that in an
actionable envelope and they stick it in
their outbox for franz kafka's cousin to
pick up and go and effectively take
towards the chef
the chef
decides whether or not they can fulfill
the order we've got the ingredients
we're too busy et cetera and with
assuming they choose to accept the order
then essentially he will effectively
send the order request over to the
delivery desk
the delivery desk is probably
me phoning my cousin bob uh to decide
whether or not essentially bob's car is
working and he can actually deliver the
order for us if so what bob will tend to
do is basically say that's fine i can
probably deliver to the customer at 7 15
and he sends a message back from his out
box he puts two messages in the outbox
one will say
hey i'm going to deliver the order at 7
30 to the chef so the chef knows i
better start cooking that at 10 past
and the other one goes back basically to
the order taking team uh to say can you
fax back to just paper take away to tell
them the order's been accepted
we then get our fax back right
and again we must have usually
effectively at some point we've got a
file we get that
the request back and we say look up that
order in the file and say okay that
order is now completed
and we can effectively raise something
to say
okay we now have basically an accepted
order at the restaurant and again
this flow is asynchronous right
i get in something to my inbox
asynchronously i put it over a fax
machine the other team get it in
by their fax machine
put it in their out box it goes to the
chef into his inbox he actions it puts
it in his out box it goes to the driver
booking they action it and so
effectively okay i've got they raised
two messages one to the shaft one back
to us and that asynchronous flow comes
across and we pick up our file that says
hey um that order is now complete and
raised a computer message from our
outbox
and that then flows to our customer
customer agents a customer agents
receive that in their inbox and they
have basically a request that's a thing
saying this order has been basically
successfully placed with a restaurant
and it's they say they're going to
deliver at 7 30 and i then phone up the
customer and say
your food is coming at 7 30. and that
would be a synchronous conversation at
this point unless we decide you know
we're living in a world where sms exists
in which case i you know i text you or
whatever right but
again that's another synchronous part of
the flow potentially
all right
and you can see overall
that there are two things that are
happening
one we can think of as flow right
it's this asynchronous conversation
there are information packets moving
between desks where people are taking
actions and hustling when effectively
somebody is actually doing some work
they take a thing out of the inbox and
they and they do whatever their
particular function is
right work on whatever we've got and
then they potentially raise some new
message to their outbox
and that is really the model right that
is the model of effectively how we build
software
that we want to work in an asynchronous
fashion we need to think about
individual processing desks
where a particular part a particular
business process is carried out
and think about a flow
of kind of inbox to outbox
that says you do your step okay there's
a okay we'll hand it off next question
does their step we'll hand it off next
person does that step so you can see we
have that we have a synchronous flow
there you probably can't see the colors
on the screen
um
this onboarding of a restaurant is
effectively all asynchronous at that
point right don't worry about that
detail
um
and then we basically produce that
catalog it goes basically to our order
taking team to the customer that's
asynchronous it's just going by snail
mail right and then essentially there is
this
synchronous call from the customer
which then effectively we take their
order
and then essentially there's an
asynchronous flow placing it with the
restaurant the restaurant booking its
driver confirming the order and us then
basically responding with a synchronous
call at the end but
the thing i wanted to take away from
this is not the detail on this diagram
but an understanding that when we built
paper-based systems
we just consistently worked in a mostly
asynchronous fashion that is the norm
that's what we've done for hundreds of
years
synchronous
internal models of your system are
actually the abnormality
what about errors what about errors in
asynchronous systems this is by the way
in case some of you've never seen it
when you're when you send a fax
you get a fax receipt
and the fax receipt has a code
right on the end and it tells you
basically whether your facts were sent
or not right
okay
so what would happen for example
if uh my uh
order taking team
have got an order they've got a request
in their inbox they've opened up a file
um and they send the order over to the
restaurant right
and they get an uh receipt back off the
fax machine and that says
there's an error
what happens generally what happens
normally we just retry right
just say let's try sending that facts
again i've got a copy on file probably
all right and i resend the copy that i
got on file
so
copies on file so the model we used to
use was this right basically carbon
paper
so i write on the top sheet
and it presses on the bottom sheet below
which is carbon paper it takes an
impression of it and i then have a copy
of the message that i intended to send
if the message gets lost
then essentially i have a carbon copy i
can send
all right
so imagine
that you are phoning up just paper take
one you want to be on board and the
sales team and you agree the contract
and the sales team puts a message into
that outbox for franz kafka to deliver
um to our team take menu
and it turns out uh what you want to do
is create a file saying here is my
sales account for this customer right
and i put a copy a carbon copy of the
message i intend to send to the team
that process the menu request on my file
and if for some reason franz kafka is
having a bad day and he loses
essentially my message
then when effectively the customer tends
to phone me up and say well i have not
been onboarded yet onto your into a
lovely new catalogue i've seen two
catalogs go by my restaurant's not in it
i can take the copy out of my uh file
and resend it to the processing order
team
and today you may be aware of terms like
outbox or log tailing and that's what we
use in asynchronous systems what we're
doing is we're simply saying keep a copy
of the message that you have sent to
everyone downstream
such that in the event that there is a
failure of that message to be
transmitted to the downstream you can
just resend it
indeed
what about declined transactions right
and they see in this kind of process
what happens if the customer
uh was to be declined so we'll modify
the process a little bit right and we'll
assume somehow that the order payment
um uh i was showing the line to a phone
but let's say assuming we want to do the
order proceeding somehow asynchronously
we put a request in with the customers
details and the order team effectively
then uh went away and did a card holder
not present without the customer on the
phone we assume just say give us your
details we'll run it through the credit
card machine
um uh and we'll let you know there's a
problem
so what happens in that case is just a
new flow right in the event effectively
your transaction is declined
we simply put a message in our outbox
which goes to vector of the inbox of the
customer agent saying
customer's car was declined please can
you request to present a new card
and generally speaking because that
happens infrequently
we may decide that's okay there's a risk
we might have to get hold of the
customer but that's fine he doesn't get
any food at that point right there's no
process of validated order and because
most of our transactions go through
without a problem there's no point in
asking the customer to wait on the line
okay
all right
so hopefully
that helps you a little bit
i'm just gonna take a quick drink of
water
if anyone has a question at that point
you can ask it's fine
don't have to be quiet
no we're good
all right we are software engineers
not paper engineers so although it's
useful to think about it this way
is there any more advice which is more
practical for software engineers
so flow based programming was created by
paul morrison who worked for ibm in the
kind of 70s and 80s it still has some
life particularly if you go and look at
the kind of um
reactive architectures movement the
active architectures movement is aware
of flow based programming and occasion
and i think there are a couple of
float-based programming
tools out there
and it sits along things like data flow
etc and similar kind of reactive ideas
now what happened was this is the
dominant paradigm that we got
so objects on the right hand side
effectively are state and behavior right
so i capture some state and i put it in
an object and i say any methods that
effectively depend upon that state
in other words behaviors that basically
require that state go on the object
right and in a good world we hide the
state
unfortunately due to orms except we've
ended up exposing all our state's
properties but that's a different talk
for a different day
and we use what's called call and
returns what does call and return mean
so call and return says everything
starts generally with a with a with a
method called main
and in main i call an obj method on an
object
and that method on the object does some
work and it calls method another object
which calls a method on another object
and eventually at some point something
in the chain goes i'm going to return
and the flow of control passes back to
the thing that we've called it and then
back and back and back and eventually
we hit the return on main and the
program ends right
so that's why it's called it's called
basically call and return that is the
dominant paradigm that we all use today
nearly every language you're writing
so so paul morrison's alternative is
this flow-based programming so we'll
start on the left-hand side
so the key idea is this thing called the
information packet which is an
independent structure piece of
information with a well-defined lifetime
from creation and destruction
and in fbp the ip contains the state it
flows they are out they're not in
storage what do we mean by that the data
does not live in an object
right the data lives in an information
packet it looks quite separately to the
code that essentially has the behavior
we pass these information packets around
the component
is where behavior happens right in fep
the component contains the behavior so
what happens is an information packet
flows into a component via a port the
point where a connection makes uh
contact with a process right so in other
words in our i go into our report into
my component the import with node in
says information packets coming in i do
some work on it and then it flows a new
information packet usually flows out of
the out port right
and the model in flow-based programming
is you say what are the behaviors what
are the
hustles the pieces of process of busy
work that i need to do
right
what information flows into them for
them to be able to act and what
information flows out of them when they
are done
if you think about it that's exactly the
model we've just been talking about with
pre-automation systems i have an inbox
and i have an out box i have an import
and i have an outport
i have
i have i have memos and i have files i
have information packets
right that are flowing
through my system
so an ip has a lifetime once a component
has consumed an ip it deletes it
components use queues
points so i'm distinguishing q and
stream so q we effectively take a piece
of work we lock it and say i'm the one
basically reading that
essentially when we finish with it we
delete it so nobody else processes it
right whereas an event stream is you
move a pointer through effectively and
other people can process the same
message so cueing semantics because we
want to basically say i've got this
piece of work when i have consumed this
piece of work i delete it no one else
needs to do that piece of work it's been
actioned and i raised basically a result
doing that work an information packet
going out
the component
has ports
and those ports we tend to say in flow
based programming what you want to do is
basically think about a logical
distraction so paul is abstracted away
from domain logic it's a logical address
in which things are related to which
things are dispatched if you see
people uh doing firebase programming in
code they will simply say it's like
something like send to in or rather read
from in send it to out right and i'll
just use basically an abstraction to
represent the port your domain code just
uses an abstraction
we do the same thing in messaging we
talk about channels there are virtual
pipe which you address i mean if you
think about topics on kafka routine keys
on rabbit mq they are all effectively
names we can give to ports right you can
have multiple ports and connectors
generally
you know you you may receive a number of
signals you may pump out a number of
signals
uh in
uh ports can have multiple
uh types of information packet on the
same port because you may want to be
sequencing them i put them in an order
right so you basically may say this has
to come before this so you have to read
this one first then you can read this
one next so they have to use the same
import right and on out ports we only
tend to use one thread to write to an
individual port so we can preserve
sequencing of things going out of the
port as well
right and that's very similar actually
the way some things like event streams
work today and we tend to basically only
have one thread processing them when we
effectively need to make sure that we
have uh make sure that a thread is only
pushing out one item at time in order
and what happens is we make more complex
systems by hooking together components
right so think unix pipes and filter
style architectures right
i have a component it receives an
information packet it does some
transformation it produces more
information packets which go to other
components right and we refer to that
and focus programming as a network
and then what we can do is we can
simplify our reasoning about things by
taking a number of
uh components a network and saying well
i can think about this
as actually
a component right because it has an in
and it has an out so i can just really
avoid the detail and just reason about
this larger macro idea of things
something that goes in and out so
they're a subnet right
and so subnets are collections of
components to kind of fulfill a purpose
and we'll see that in a second
how we use that
okay
so let's go through that same just paper
take away flow again
but this time
let's think of it in terms of flow based
programming okay
so start the left-hand side this dotted
line basically is going to indicate a
subnet
in which we have three components by the
way right uh we have a qualify
restaurant request it doesn't make
catalog so that's our sales process
that's our team basically requesting
details from the restaurant the menu
that's basically our graphics department
making the catalog right we've got ports
between them out and in out and in so we
just think we're just trying to
capitalize on that inbox our box idea
for you right work comes into my inbox
comes into my in port right leaves while
my outbox goes out for my out port right
now in fbp what we do is we treat
basically a ui it's just a stream of
information coming into basically uh our
subnet
and then what happens is we go basically
through a qualify restaurant we pretty
much do some validation of what we've
received over the ui and then comes to
request details where we have to fax the
restaurant we're not going to show the
restaurant side of the equations for
simplicity
and what happens here is that a
component may have state which enables
it to correlate between ips that arrive
across time for example storing the
details request until it gets a fax menu
response that then passes along with
details so that's what we're saying is
i fax you something i'm going to need to
get a correlation id on it you're going
to give me a response a bit later i'm
doing other work in the meantime i'll
pick up that correlation id and i will
essentially say hey this is the response
to that request
and that also means
this kind of component needs storage
and it needs storage because the
requested may need storage to be
reliable it takes work from the import
but kind of sent to the output without
waiting for the correlated fax input and
output which is asynchronous what would
be dropped if we lost the process
without being able to recover where we
were in other words because i'm waiting
what happens if i crash any work in
flight will be lost if it's just a
memory so i store waiting requests into
a database right interestingly enough
and something i often point out to my
colleagues is
in this entire subnet which we could
think of potentially as a micro service
because it's a business process that
we're aligned with right in this entire
subnet it's only really this step in the
middle that actually requires us to
store on a thing
everything else could actually rely on
the storage provided to us by cues
now it's quite a ballsy move but you may
find that actually we could remove quite
a lot of databases from our systems
because if we've got cues they're
actually acting as a data store for work
that's in flight and you only need them
for reliability in between it
okay
so let's get the order food one right
remember order food have a customer the
customer basically goes to where we're
going to validate and price the order
once we have validated and prices price
to order it or go to take payment where
we'll basically say hey bank can i take
the payment for that or take the payment
right customer again basically has a ui
which is being treated basically it's a
stream of information packets coming in
to take order
flowbase programming calls the i this
idea a lookup it's the same thing we're
talking about pattern calls at reference
data we saw it as basically a paper
catalog right it's how do i validate and
price the order so somewhere off screen
is effectively our our earlier system
which is produced effectively a stream
of information packets which we use to
build a table
and then at take order time i just
simply look up in that table and say hey
is this a valid item at that restaurant
hey how much does this cost okay great i
can then price and validate the order
using that lookup data and we do this
all the time with things like event
carriage state transfer and messaging um
internally actually at jesse tech we
call them projections where effectively
we have a cache of data that's come from
another system which we use to do things
like validate and price stuff etc right
okay
so take that lookup data and then
effectively i'm going to take the
payment um the interesting thing to note
here is that um there's a synchronous
conversation really here going on with
the card reader i basically effectively
put it in the bank replies right so
essentially we say the synchronous
request response conversation with the
credit card company which is outside of
our control
the cardboard component turns this into
an asynchronous conversation for take
payment which can thus be used for
retries means we can use the correct
over storage for a live that's what i
mean by that if we take payment we
create a card reader component which has
the synchronous conversation i can queue
requests to the card reader
and wait for responses from the card
when they've been actioned so if the
card reader is a constrained component
in other words i can only make so many
requests at any one given time when the
card reader it doesn't matter i'm just
queuing work eventually it arrives back
with a correlation id and i know that
order's now been paid for
so uh the whole subnet looks
asynchronous even though there's a
synchronous component basically to it
because it comes by in and out
okay
then we get into the easy world order
placement right i'm just doing a fax
machine we saw that earlier so
effectively again we need our
correlation id and again we'll need some
storage
and you can see that between subnets
the flow is completely asynchronous
right
i have a catalog which becomes look up
data for my service not to do the work
of validating and pricing i place the
order effectively um
the order basically does the fax machine
effectively goes over the side oh and
i've got credit card interaction which
effectively looks asynchronous from the
outside
and even within
those
subnets those micro services if you like
most of the interaction apart from this
call to the reader is asynchronous
okay does flow-based programming help us
with basically the the error flows we
saw earlier
okay
so this is basically the one where
effectively your payment fails
to daisy what did i do there well it
wasn't me we're okay
so generally error is a report
we send out errors in flow based
programming on another port we just say
there's a port for errors
okay so here what we're saying is if we
have a card error we can just raise it
to an error port to signal that we
transformed the request ip please take
payment into an error ip no payment was
successfully taken
okay
just for me i've done that just see if
sorry it's the second i will get that
back for you
there we go
um
and the errors flow so here what you can
see is that in response to me receiving
a signal on the error
for that particular payment i can then
basically say right i will raise a card
error so i will basically raise the
information packet on the card airport
and my take order component has an in
new card required port which basically
receives messages from that card error
information packet and essentially i
then basically place it on an order
error report which on the ui basically
effectively would probably
use a push notification that the
customer saying card decline please can
you present a new one right
and we do this all the time messaging
right think of these error ports as
we're just saying hey you know what
there's an error i'll just raise a
message
just for an error to start an error flow
through my system to handle that error
rather than the flow effectively for the
for the good request
okay
all right
so how can we
how can we use these ideas
to build reliable systems today so the
key i think i've found over time is to
make sure
that when we model what the components
are in our system microservices if you
like
[Music]
that they need to be designed to be
these individual processing steps that
have kind of an inbox and an outbox and
you're doing busy work in the middle and
the problem i see a lot is when people
try and split
across in the middle of the busy work
so i've got something comes in
and i go away and i basically say oh my
job now is to basically validate that
request and i'm going to make a call
halfway through validating this request
to this other service i like validating
price right and effectively i say oh i'm
going to do this work and then i'm going
to make a call halfway through
uh to a synchronous this other system
over here
and then get the response back but that
seems to be synchronous because this all
seems like one transaction so we have
examples like you know um i want to give
you a price
uh and it includes delivery and includes
um offers and actually that really is a
transaction and the more i split that
the harder it is for me to do work right
and the problem is when you tend to
build systems where you are splitting
the busy work in the middle rather than
thinking about where is the outbox
moment where is the moment when i've
done my work and handed it over if i am
in processing i would generally tend to
be doing one or two things look up
to data that i've received
asynchronously and having some catalog
form to help me do my work
or making a synchronous request because
i have to talk to the bank to validate
your payment details etc there is no way
around that synchronous problem at that
point right
so
let me show you a couple of techniques
that you may all be already be aware of
and how you use them as models so value
stream mapping is very useful because
value stream mapping is designed to
really work in an asynchronous
fashion
so i'm not it's not a session about
value stream mapping but i will give you
a little bit of an idea of how it works
so the first thing you do basically is
you decide what am i going to model
and generally it's one of two things
it's either a journey for a customer
uh saying i want to buy some food or
it's what which is called basically uh
operational or it's environmental which
basically says something that i need to
do to support my ability to service
customers
um so for example
probably many of you are staying at
hotels and maybe like if you're staying
at a hotel
checking at your
uh effectively hotel is essentially a
process right
but there are operational things to
support the check-in flow which ends
actually when you check out
like um
figure out how much money ian has spent
in the minibar right you know ian got
drunk and he ate the toblerone bar and
needs to go on his bill
okay
so
kick off we decide what are we going to
model
then what you do is offensively you walk
the process and in fact when value
stream mapping has they have this idea
called go to the gambler which is
basically walk the actual floor of the
process physically but you quite we we
quite often can't do that in the
software but the idea effectively is you
walk through and what you want to do is
look for what we call the handovers
so you want to look for the point at
which somebody says i do this
to this piece of info this information
packet comes in essentially this bit of
data comes in i process it in some way
and then there's a result which is this
right
those are handovers and those are
actually the points where a
synchronicity is likely to be possible
right
and you divide up your value stream
probably in summary of the order of five
to 15 steps that have handovers
and then essentially you just get
a whiteboard a big glass wall
effectively you get post-it notes
and you use the post put the post-it
notes in a line and use them to
represent the individual steps in the
process
and that gives you effectively the flow
here are the individual steps here the
individual handoffs
so here you can see
we're looking at the sales inquiry for
the for restaurant owner restaurant
owner effectively says okay
we think there's an onboarding inquiry
within the onboarding inquiry results
basically in a handover of we need to
basically get this restaurant signed up
that goes to our team that basically
manage the menu and they will hand off
when they've got the menu details to the
team that publishes the catalogue right
so that gives us a flow
we then do a second walk and the second
war tends to start at the other end and
go backwards to say how do we get here
so in our case a second walk would be we
have a catalog
that has the details of our restaurants
in it how did we get the details of the
restaurants in
oh okay well we have to have a prior
step
where essentially
the the catalogue was produced well how
did they get the menu details well
there's a prior step where they asked
the restaurant okay how do we know to
ask the restaurant or there's a prior
step where a salesman sold them
basically the idea of working for just
paper takeaway
and then generally in value stream
mapping you add details like lead time
process time percentage of completions
and you get one of these
and i find valuation map is a really uh
quite useful way of doing it because
forcing people to think about these
handovers gives you these individual
process steps
which then tend to be useful to think
about hey these things may well have
asynchronous handoffs between them
so event storming is kind of the poster
child in this area from alberto
brandolini and that ddd folks in the
audience probably have met event
storming in the past again this is not
even stormy teaching session but we'll
run through it and highlight the level
details that you can understand and work
with it
but one of the problems i often find
when i do an event storming session
is
people start to worry about what we mean
by event
generally when you do eventually we tend
to have a mixed audience so some tech
people but also the product people even
the delivery people on the team
an event means a different thing to all
of them right so devs immediately start
thinking about when we say event of
something i'm sending to kafka or to
azure service bus or whatever sns right
so they start thinking technically
the product team have no idea what you
mean by event that's generally a party
they go to
and delivery basically essentially are a
bit nonplussed and trying to negotiate
between product and tech other meaning
of event right and it's very unclear
event storming about what is an event
okay
i tend to think of events what i tend to
tend to get people to do in a mixed
audience is say it's something you are
shoving into your outbox
right
you've done some work and you generate i
say think about paper-based flow when
we're doing about stormy rather than
thinking about computer systems because
they all think about existing systems
they have i see when you're thinking
about event storming let's imagine we're
modeling this as bits of paper right
paper based flow and that tends i find
to make it much easier for them and you
say what is the thing that i'm sticking
into my outbox right so what is this
information packet and flow based
programming terms what is the data that
i am i i get as a result of a
transformation events tends to be a bit
too technical as a term
so with event stormy
our goal is to essentially
look at everything to the lens of events
okay
so once you've then identified the gaps
between events represent processes that
must transform one event into another
or aggregates um i'll talk about
aggregates and process in a second and
come on to initiate flows in other words
basically something has to kick this off
so basically has to be an initial theme
which says hey i'm going to tell you to
transform basically this information
packet into another one okay so
traditionally this is kind of the model
you would use you have an event one
color post-it note you have an aggregate
and aggregate basically is
some statement behavior
view basically which is essentially
[Music]
allows a customer to make decisions by
effectively having a lookup data so
think of that as our catalog data
and commands which initiate flow now
when i tend to do events from one of the
things i've switched away from is using
aggregates to just use the idea of a
process why because when you look at
this idea the problem is that thinking
about aggregates thinking about state
it doesn't actually help us to think
really about asynchronicity between
systems and you quite often end up with
people modeling um
entity entity services
i tend to say people just think about a
process it's amorphous it's some kind of
thing some kind of behavior that is
transforming commands into events right
or events into other events
that tends to i find it much easier i
think aggregate is a bit of a
it's a ddd-ism that doesn't actually
help very much
okay
and so uh here the
things that go out boxes well there's
this idea restaurant has signed up uh
which is essentially saying i want to
get details
there's this idea basically effectively
that i have some menu details that i've
received from the restaurant and this is
idea that i've got this new restaurant
catalog those who would seem to be the
key
outbox elements that get raised
then effectively i just need to figure
out as a process
that transforms these things there's one
that manages catalogue ones obtains
restaurant details and one agrees the
contract which results in those which is
all kicked off by this commander at my
restaurant and i find this is a much
easier way of doing event storming um
because it gets the same result but i
think it's a bit clearer for the the
non-techies in the audience uh and
putting the non-ddd people in the
audience
so again here's another model restaurant
catalog updated order taken order raised
we can simply transform that like this
with the green restaurant catalog
representing where we're doing lookup
data so it's a read-only copy of our
data which we can use effectively to do
lookups with
similarly
placing an order
and similarly order confirmation
there's another technique to be aware of
uh called event modelling by adam
demetric it's very similar to event
storming but it's much more detailed
and what it focuses on is it says i want
to actually know what is the data in
those information packets
because if i know what the information
is in the information packet i can tell
you did the customer enter that did i
have to get it from another service and
it lets you effectively trace data
requirements
it's expensive because it takes a long
time to do but it can be useful if
you're struggling a bit
okay
so what does that mean in a kind of
world of micro services how does this
perspective
change how we might think about it
so i'd argue that essentially too many
people are still building things which
are effectively web services era
services
and what they do
is essentially they say
i've got a service which is modeled in
an oo fashion
it has state and it has behavior applied
to that state all in the one service
and you call me to effectively
apply transformations to my state and
the problem we tend to get is two-fold
one is they tend to work better
synchronously and two that the key
workflow logic tends to move out
basically of here to some orchestrating
component
and i would say what we need to think
about much more as services that look
like this
in the microservices area where
effectively we see the service as a
process that's doing transformation
on information packets that are flowing
through our system
right and we should distinguish our
universe between
these things that flow which effectively
actually really sense the heart of our
program and these bits of hustling we
have to do to do that transformation
and that will help you build
asynchronous systems
all right
i think i'm done i actually have about
five minutes for questions which is a
bit unusual or you can all be so tired
and lunch lunch
uh sleepy that you want to go away does
anyone have a question they want to ask
oh there's a question okay tell me the
question i'll repeat it for the for the
mic
so you are basically flow-based
programming programs there are some
there's some there are some flow-based
programming uh things out there i can't
remember what there's a javascript one
that's quite um
famous the fluid based programming
community thinks they're not quite
flow-based programming they're a little
bit different they tend to be associated
quite a lot with the low code movement
i
am
i think it's interesting uh
my reach into flow-based programming was
far more looking at the reactive
architecture kind of style ideas behind
that
of saying we ought to focus really on
the separation of state and behavior
when we think about modeling
architecture at a bigger level
um i'm less less worried about um modern
attempts to use flow-based programming
to produce
um
an execute coding execution environment
in the small inside the service
um but they are interesting um but yeah
i think the fluids programming community
has some recent comments up about why
they don't why they think they're uh
they're not quite actually flow based
programming even though they came they
claimed to be
good question
manifestation okay that's a really good
question
all right
so sergeant psychopaths
don't really know uh so the idea was
that people realize that you can't do
transactions that span
multiple um microservices very easily
because there's no distributed
transaction coordinator doesn't scale
very well so the idea was really to
produce a state machine which would say
i understand the workflow
and what i can do is control each of the
steps in the workflow by saying do this
then do this then do this and control
error flows
that's what we tend to call basically
orchestration because there's basically
a conductor the other alternative is
what we call choreography and
choreography says we don't actually need
a conductor we can just essentially
pre-arrange all the flows by just simply
connecting inboxes to outboxes and
having error flows and simply knowing
the whole thing goes through i tend to
prefer
choreography to orchestration
because the trouble with orchestration
is it creates this bottleneck single
point of failure that contains all my
workflows
but in some cases it can be useful to do
that kind of orchestration such as when
i need to think about the reservation
pan where i want i've got you've got 10
minutes to fulfill this and that kind of
thing etc right but i think prefer
choreography where effectively we say
hey i can just
follow the roots of him of of
uh connections between in and out or
error flows and that will give me
basically my pattern of flow around the
whole system i don't need an external
manager of my pipeline that's the same
problem we have in part line
architecture that's right pipe
supporters architectures have this have
this conflict between does someone
control the flow through the pipeline or
is it just basically flying from
component to component i tend to prefer
the latter because it doesn't require an
orchestrator but both are useful
techniques
anybody else
all right then i think we're probably
done thank you very much for coming
listening and i hope it wasn't too
threatening after lunch
okay
[Applause]
please remember it's customer to put the
green ticket in the box outside that's
how it works